from timcast.com Kevin McCarthy says
Congress will hold D.A Bragg accountable
get him the D.A is attempting to
interfere in our Democratic process by
invoking federal law to bring
politicized charges against President
Trump
he cited politicized charges by the New
York D.A in a statement
uh Bragg is Bragg's openization of the
federal Justice process will be held
accountable by Congress all right well
you know I'm not going to hold my breath
for Kevin McCarthy or anything like that
but we'll maybe we'll see something the
problem is they don't have any authority
to put anybody in jail so we can expose
all this stuff and but the D.A I mean
not the D.A the the justicism the doj is
not going to do anything with any of the
findings I mean we see that all the time
all they have is subpoena power and even
when they have subpoena power they will
not enforce it they will not say oh you
you were called you didn't testify or
you lied how many people do you see all
the time testifying hearings that lie
under oath to Congress which is a
jailable offense and nothing happens to
them so there is no accountability when
it comes to Congress other than a
fact-finding missions which everybody
seems to politicize anyway but I still
think it needs to be done but I really
think all the all the Republican DA's in
this country need to get their busting
gear for sure I agree 100 the more that
the Republicans and conservatives can
use the government to attack their
opponents do it do it it's on it's
already hit it they already yeah do it
hearings subpoenas do it all of it
punish them punish them
I think that's a that's that's a bad way
to think about it
Republicans for the longest time have
been spineless and cowardly there's not
we don't need to punish anybody we need
the law we need them to be like we're
just gonna do the bare minimum of law
enforcement Hunter Biden bare minimum
special prosecutor it's law fair tie
them up in hearings but it's not it's
not even this is the problem if the
rights view of standard law enforcement
is a special circumstance in which we
get revenge this is why Republicans
never go after Democrats when they break
the law
it's like well Barack Obama murdered a
16 year old but because I don't want
revenge we're gonna let it slide
so this idea that we have to get revenge
on them I don't care about revenge I
just want Justice one time I want to see
Barack Obama in handcuffs being brought
into a criminal court for the murder of
Abdul Rahman al-alaki instead Donald
Trump paid a hooker and that's what the
the spectacle is so they would have
gotten him for jaywalking like like
that's where it really is if they had
that when you entered the courthouse Mr
Mr former president UJ walked I mean I'm
just saying like Republicans don't do
anything this is the time that they need
to get on it they they need to get their
butts in gear but what's going to
motivate them because they know that the
voters are still going to vote for them
right like that's their incentive is are
they going to be re-elected there's no
incentive for them to go harder than it
is other than our country failing but
there's what a handful maybe three or
four that we like that have a backbone
like that
cowards they're cow they're they're so
few conservatives that will do anything
they they absolutely should do I think
that they should use every means the
that the law allows to go after their
political opponents for every single
violation if they have if they yeah
think about what the logic of that
statement is we let them break the law
that's that's what it sounds like you're
saying no no I'm saying I'm saying we're
doing that now go after them for every
violation of the law the government
right but it's not punishment it's not
Revenge it's not just accountability
it's just the standard process of law
enforcement it's been ignored by the
Republicans absolutely and and they have
re ignored it they've been ignoring it
Donald Trump himself ignored the law he
allowed so what we should have a uh
it's like this it's like uh when when
the Democrats say high capacity magazine
and they refer to anything above 10 10
Rounds despite the fact that rifles come
with 30 round magazines as standard
when we say like we want we want revenge
we want punishment we want you know go
after them on every infraction it's it's
the same thing it's like no no here's
what I'm here's on the phrase it I would
like the Republicans to do at as little
as possible
as little as possible
little little teeny teeny bit the least
amount they can do because right now
they're doing nothing yeah I I would ask
they only do a little bit it's kind of
like their friends and then maybe maybe
after that so uh one thing they can do I
guess is um how about in Colorado we get
any D.A any single one because there's
no statute of limitations on murder or
San Diego where Abdul Vermont Allah he
also lived and San Diego you got you got
any Republicans down there there's no
statute of limitations on murder indict
Barack Obama do it you you spineless
cowards I mean can we just start with
just let's just start with the the Lefty
weirdos that are protesting all the time
look at Tennessee they've got a a
republican Governor they've got
Republican DA's right Bill Lee he's the
the Republican governor of Tennessee
start hunting down and Prosecuting every
person that trespassed in that Capital
because that's what they did you know
charged them with a felony charge them
with um you know
interrupting a civil proceeding right
that's four years in prison because all
our guys are sitting there rotting away
for that for four years just do the
least amount you can because right now
you're doing nothing
I I understand what you're the argument
you're making essentially it's a
narrative argument right um just which
is which is fair but uh I mean I I don't
care how we classify it I think that the
narrative art I think the narrative is
probably not going to be won by the
right
um because the narrative is going to be
at least be so heavily no The Narrative
is not going to be able to be dictated
but I don't care about winning a
narrative against the left those people
don't matter to me it's like asking me
what I think about the people of France
like well I've heard about what they do
I don't care the issue is we keep going
to conservatives and asking telling them
putting it in their minds that what we
are asking for is lifting a two-ton
Stone when in fact we're asking
Republicans pick up a measly little
Pebble dude we are when we come out we
say we need our politicians to go out
and go after every infraction instead of
being like can we please get a single
Republican to do the least amount of
work possible yeah yeah I I get what
you're saying it's it's it's for the
results that I'm after it's the the
results of that least amount of work
that I want because the results are
what's going to inhibit other political
actors from behaving that way in the
future so yes I get what you're saying
about about the minimum if people if
people think that
indicting Barack Obama is a tremendous
undertaking of abnormality that we must
now change our action and Go full force
and they won't expect it to happen if we
say the least yep the least a
conservative D.A in Colorado or San
Diego could do is indict Obama for
murder that's the least they could do
then it's more like okay well that they
should be doing that tomorrow
all right yeah if you want to talk about
escalating you know 34 charges in 136
years in prison that's a whole other
story but right now I believe
Republicans and conservatives in this
country have become such such you know
it's funny because they I love how they
make fun of soy boys how their rights
are always making fun of soy boys yet
all the conservative has in terms of law
enforcement and DA's are the soiest of
soy boys listen to this an antifa soy
Boy made fun of by conservatives will
firebomb a building and then risk going
to prison for 30 years and a
conservative D.A will be like well I I
can't charge anybody with a crime I mean
I don't think the court worked that way
and who's the real soy boy they're
they're less than soy boys I mean
they're deranged people they're when
when the left users say like there's a
big Mental Health crisis it's in this is
we have a huge Mental Health crisis and
it's nine times out of ten all these
deranged people on the left like to be
able to go and do that over some of the
issues that they are going and doing and
believing the narratives that they
believe they are absolutely deranged
I don't understand how they are deranged
I don't understand this Narrative of
these people being soy boys when there's
videos of them screaming at the top of
their lungs and smashing windows and I'm
just like yo they're they're like
psychotically aggressive some and then
but the like
I had that little one pull my hair
remember the antifa in Philly when I was
like filming a soy boy pulled your hair
yeah like it was an answer nothing about
my hair the the the the the the
smallest thing a person could do in
terms of fighting back the most
rudimentary would be pulling hair we
can't even get a republican to indict a
a Democrat for the criminal actions they
have conducted it's because we it's
because we live in the logic of Herbert
Marcus my point is the people we accuse
of being soy boys are so much stronger
than your average Republican politician
it's it's laughable that people make fun
of them for being low-t soy boys I'm
like dude at least that guy went outside
and screamed the these conservative DA's
are doing nothing in fact many of them
are working with Democrats you want to
talk about Low T soy boys purposefully
crawl under the legs of a Democrat so
they can rest their feet and then you
complain the guy outside screaming and
smashing Windows is low T sorry I I I'm
absolutely right they are working
together too and that's why like PA is
the way that it is it's like purple and
all now our our GOP is so corrupt NPA
that the Republican like uh nominees
that are winning like just little tiny
races or whatever are getting called by
the Democrat mayor congratulating them
they get they receive money you should
look into it like they receive money
from Democrat donors the Republicans in
Philadelphia itself like
it's it's baffling it's like really
mind-boggling but you're right they're
working together it's not just no the
Republicans are like Democrat political
you know uh submissives
yeah I mean it is the look you look at
what they do on TV I mean look at what
we're watching right now they indicted
Donald Trump a local district attorney a
local guy
indict Donald Trump you made it tell me
Barack Obama blew up a kid blew him up
his cousin and a bunch of civilians and
Republicans are like wow you know I
don't know if I could do anything it's
part of Hawaii dude I was reading that
why they're not going after Trump for
any kind of war crimes because they
don't want to open that can of worms
that's everybody man that's the
administrations of of Obama carrying the
letter down the hall for Obama they
opened the can of worms by indicting
Trump thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time